hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow
episode 13 video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
they're just a couple more episodes left
in the season
there are 16 episodes total they've just
released the synopsis for the finale so
I'll talk a little bit about that after
my episode 13 stuff but the big thing in
this episode is that we saw Carter again
and Hawkgirl finally started using her
mace
technically it's Carter's mace but for
the longest time in the comics you see
Hawkgirl wielding the mace they they
both have similar weapons but the TV
show has collapsed a lot of that
mythology so now it's Carter's mace that
she has modified overall pretty solid
episode most of my favorite character
scenes were between Captain Cold and
Cassandra you know no surprise there so
let's do top five WTF and I'll explain
Easter eggs as we go along there was a
bunch of comic book stuff in here but
there were a couple big changes to comic
book stuff like with the atom storyline
so let's start with number five the atom
goes big so in the comics the atom none
of the versions of the atom remember Ray
Palmer isn't the first person to be
called the atom none of them can grow
bigger so this is just the TV show doing
the giant man thing from the Marvel
Universe like well he can go smaller
wouldn't it be fun to see him go bigger
to to fight this giant robot so all in
the name had awesome special effects
sequence in the robot actually like the
symbol on him looks a lot like he was
modified from Palmer tech if you
remember they had been co-opted by the
military during that episode we learned
that after he was believed to be dead
during arrow season 3 after that big
explosion in the finale
his brother wormed his way into the
company and took credit for all of his
designs and then passed it on to the
military so I'll address some of the
continuity problems but this is one of
those because it's like why would
Felicity let them use his technology in
this way so you know something clearly
very bad happened in that timeline
that's the same timeline where we got
one armed Oliver Stephen Amell had a
good explainer for all that he said that
that's a potential future if the heroes
are not successful and do not come back
so think of all this stuff they're
seeing in this future here like whenever
they go to fight Vandal Savage in the
future as darkest timeline arrow and
flash the problem is and I'll talk about
this later too is that if they kill
Vandal Savage in the future then that
won't stop all that other stuff from
happening in the past that will still
have happened so there's gonna have to
be some other solution they got to
remove him from the timeline some other
way but giant atom vs. giant robot it
was a lot of fun you know I feel like
if they have more time to work on these
effects sequences and plan them out
they'll be even better in season two the
number four WTF meet vandal savage's
daughter so in the comics there's two
big daughters that you meet during a
couple different comic book runs there's
another one that they just did recently
where there's a whole bunch of children
that he has but he's immortal he's lived
for thousands of years it stands to
reason he's gonna have a couple kids
walking around the way they explain it
this child was alive around the time
that that virus was released so this
isn't too long after that she has some
great chemistry with Captain cold can't
wait to see if they do anything with
that and like he said my father is a lot
like your father so I do have to agree
with that analogy in Michael Ironside
who played Captain cold said he would
make an awesome Vandal Savage - I mean
he'd be much older Vandal Savage but you
get the idea number three smelting for
beginners Hawkgirl buffs her mace with
that bracelet she's finally using the
maze and she's been training with Sarah
so that that's why she's a little bit
better fighter in this episode than she
has been in previous episodes but I will
say I'm not a big fan of the way they
plotted a lot of the mythology of the
show but they're trying to simplify a
bunch of different things about vandal
savage's backstory from the comics in
Hawkman and Hawk girl's back story from
the comics there's just there's like a
whole bunch of Hawkman Hawkgirl stuff
that has absolutely nothing to do with
Vandal Savage so they're trying to
shoehorn in a lot of things and because
the season was a little rushed you just
you find a lot of these convenient
moments where it's like oh my god
she has the bracelet well we'll melt the
bracelet and then it'll totally work so
they're really rushing over a whole lot
of plot whole lot of mythology I think
you know they want those character
moments where like Hawkgirl comes to the
conclusion like oh I know how to do this
I know how to defeat him but I feel like
they're ignoring some of the most
interesting stuff from the show like
this is comic-book stuff so the
mythology is super deep they can have
way more fun with it in season two
imagine watching the first three Indiana
Jones films you know the good ones and
what would they look like if they cut
out all the scenes where Indy talks
about the cool history behind the places
and the objects imagine them cutting
that out and then just saying here's
this really awesome object it burns
people's eyes out of their sockets
without all the scenes that provide the
context for why that's so awesome
whatever number two WTF Cassandra turns
on vandal savage you get the sense that
he really cares about her I was actually
waiting for some twist like maybe this
is the daughter that he misappropriated
like it belonged to someone else and he
just co-opted urns like I'm gonna raise
my own we really don't know anything
about his wife that's one of the other
problems of the show is that it just
provides you with these plot points
without completely explaining things so
maybe we'll find out about her mother in
a future episode it'll be a lot of fun
to see her fight her father but I feel
like this is one of those other moments
where they just rush over like how
strong was that her bond that all it
took for her to completely turn against
him was to say he did something evil
because even captain cold who had to
live with his father for all those years
and knew how evil he was he knew about
the terrible things his father had done
took him years and years to get to the
point where he turned against them so
just more rushing of character
development that I feel like they can
address in season two but number one WTF
Hawk man is reincarnated he comes back
but Vandal Savage has turned him
they can't kill him because he hasn't
brainwashed so I totally understand the
twist that they're going forward they
want that oh moment like oh my god
it's Carter and they want Hawkgirl to
have this impossible situation but just
like the way they executed it just did
not work for me at all so even if you're
really nice and you don't poke holes in
all the logic which I feel is like a
completely separate problem then I feel
like they need to work on earning their
big reveal moments and this just felt
like it came out of nowhere it's a lot
like Jax beating the father that he
never knew we didn't know anything about
Jackson's father before the first
episode he appeared in so you just when
you get to that really emotional moment
it doesn't really feel that emotional
it's like oh well that's I guess that's
nice am I supposed to feel sad about
this I don't know so I know a lot of you
guys are asking me about you know
lodging stuff so let's have a little bit
of fun like I don't I don't try to be
too mean because a lot of the show I
feel like there's a lot of good things
here it could be really good in season
two just as long as they do a better job
of plying it out and weaving in the
mythology in a really interesting way
without trying to speed over things too
much or oversimplify but let me know in
the comments what do you think the
solution to defeating Vandal Savage is
gonna be because there are a couple
rules about how they kill him and they
need to get Carter's mind back but I
know a lot of you are still wondering
are they ever gonna address what Merlyn
did with his ashes that feels like it
could be a really awesome scene just
watching him regenerate himself so a
whole bunch of Game of Thrones stuff
happening tomorrow but while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my flash trailer for next
week and you can click here to learn all
about the Game of Thrones episode titles
for this season thank you
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight